i'd like to get serious for a moment um
it's been over a year since george floyd
was brutally murdered at the hands of a
police officer and yet the senate still
has not passed a police reform bill
there's talk of a framework for a bill
and negotiations but no real action
that's ridiculous they should have
passed the police reform bill by now
well maybe they're just having a tough
time getting bills passed in general you
know i thought the same thing but that's
not the case
that's right
there's been a lot of talk about police
reform it seems like ignoring it is just
the norm
they haven't been able to pass a law
it's true
but there are a lot of laws that they've
gotten around
like what the alaska tourism restoration
act to make sure that their tourism
still grows the 1921 silver dollar point
anniversary act what's that i don't
know we've got like seven bills about
lakes and storms but what hasn't passed
you get this there's no police reform a
lease for more police
[Applause]
[Music]
oh that's not so many bills pass oh baby
shut your mouth we're just get started
the faster act of 2021
to make sure that food is labeled
properly the transplant act of 2021
make sure donors are connected to people
in need the advancing education on
biosimilars act it probably took one
hell of a brainstorm
they even passed the future
which we may not get to see
if police reform don't get passed
quickly
so
there's no police
[Music]
police reform it's something that we're
never gonna get
lest you think us liars misrepresenting
our officials
here's a list of the rest of the bills
that have passed without any issues
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wait
what is that
national police week national police
week
yeah it's a week to celebrate police
before police reform
wow i thought y'all were just singing a
fun little song yeah it's real
our hopelessness is real
well dang
there's no police reform police
[Music]
[Music]
there's no police
[Music]
[Applause]
we're all in danger
[Music]
you